the SCP Foundation is home to plenty of
anomalies whose reputations precede them
here at SCP explained we've discussed
quite a few of the most notable
anomalies contained by the foundation
from the wholesome half-cats and tickle
monsters to the nightmarish giant
reptiles and reality warping old men but
there are very few anomalies so popular
so famous or inFAMOUS depending on who
you ask that they attract a Non-Stop
revolving door of would-be worshipers to
suit chaos all around the foundation
what's it like to be a creature that's
always the center of attention whether
he wants to be or not today we're taking
a look at the lifestyle of the
involuntarily famous
scp-2662 we took the liberty of
observing a full day in the life of the
entity known by many as Cthulhu from his
morning routine to his bedtime and all
the little moments of unplanned chaos in
between with his permission we compiled
everything we saw into a video For Your
Entertainment welcome to a day in the
life of
scp-2662 9 A.M time to wake up stretch
your tentacles and get ready for the day
ahead add a respectable not too early
and not too late time usually around 9am
but sometimes a little bit later if he's
had a particularly late night
scp-2662 climbs out of bed and uses his
computer to throw on one of his favorite
podcasts preferred topics for listening
include game reviews and news comedic
advice podcasts and Daily News roundups
what he eats for breakfast depends on
the day but his favorite morning meals
are pancakes and huevos rancheros no
matter what he's eating he washes it
down with a tall glass of orange juice
his nutrition needs aren't like those of
a human but it's important to start the
day with a tasty meal no matter what
it's the little things that make life
worth living while he eats his breakfast
he reads a newspaper brought to him by
the foundation staff each morning
according to his request the publication
varies but no matter what he his
favorite section is arts and style or
human interest he always reads the whole
thing from front to back including the
obituaries and wedding announcements he
only gets one a day after all and he
knows it's important to appreciate
things to their fullest extent and take
nothing for granted 10 am now it's time
for scp-2660 Tuesday to really get going
he hops in the shower and listens to
another podcast as he warms up literally
he likes the water to be as hot as the
foundation will allow before they
complain about the utility bill after he
dries off he gets a hankering for a
little bit of gaming just as he starts
to settle into his gaming chair and look
through his library of video games a
member of Task Force Town 9 knocks on
the door to his containment room hey you
busy not really something going on yeah
we're just keeping an eye on a couple
religious groups of Interest according
to the chatter on the forums and a few
of the leader's social media accounts
they might be planning something
disruptive you know lots of posts about
a day of grade freedom and unleashing
the Lord of Madness upon the pathetic
World cthulhu's size must be a day that
ends in Hawaii sorry buddy the officer
shrugs not sure what else to say clearly
the two of them have spent their fair
share of days fending off mad cultists
you know the drill if anyone who's not
supposed to be here shows up start
sacrificing goats and such just let us
know hopefully it won't come to that we
should stop them before they get that
far hope so last time they got blood
everywhere and broke my copy of Resident
Evil 4. 12 p.m time flies when you're
having fun and when you're pacing back
and forth worried about cultists
breaking in to bother you with who knows
what before long it's 12 o'clock and
that means lunch time when it comes to
lunch
scp-2662 has simple tastes he likes a
good old grilled cheese and tomato soup
a bean burrito or a steaming bowl of
ramen with that he's partial to a sugary
soda or sometimes lemonade he often
likes to tune into gaming streams on
Twitch especially obscure Indie titles
or if he's feeling like something a bit
more familiar Minecraft but on this
particular day he has a visitor
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
has swung by with his own lunch to have
a catch-up chat a huge fan of meeting
other friendly anomalies especially
those completely different from himself
scp-507 often stops by cthulhu's
containment room whenever he happens to
be in the same Dimension hey Squidward
how's it going
scp-2662 hasn't seen the show that this
particular nickname came from but he
enjoys being called a friendly name
instead of some manner of esoteric title
during this visit
scp-507 shares stories of his recent
travels with
scp-2662 including his recent disturbing
brush with a smiling man and is much
more delightful time in a dimension
where he found himself on a beach where
the sand was made of popcorn and the sea
was made of Coca-Cola anywhere Cults
come by lately yeah asks after finishing
a story not a few weeks tentacles
crossed it stays that way but you know
my luck someone will probably be drawing
Arcane symbols on the walls and doing
weird chants in no time bummer 507
nodded sympathetically want to play
co-op for a bit I haven't had time in
forever sure even when it's a rare treat
it's always nice to spend time with a
friend doing something you both love
even if we can't relate much about
scp-2662's day-to-day life we can at
least relate to that it doesn't have to
be gaming either it can be painting
baking or even just watching a TV show
you love reactivity doesn't matter
nearly as much as the company after all
1 30 PM after about an hour of gaming
with scp-507
scp-2662 gets an unwelcome Interruption
just when the two enter a new dungeon
ready to take on the bosses waiting
there right when
scp-2662s to be healed
scp-507 disappears from his seat popping
over to wherever for his anomalous
Dimension hopping ability dragged him to
next oh goodbye he knows 507 can't hear
him but he wants to bid him farewell
just the same he turns to his computer
and Boots up a game he can play by
himself he only hopes his friend was
sent somewhere safe and that he'll come
back sometime soon 2 p.m at 2 o'clock
scp-2662 gets yet another unwelcome
Interruption a loud boom rocks the room
as explosives detonate nearby breaking a
wall of the containment unit open while
the mobile task forces do their best to
subdue the Invaders responsible they are
all knocked out by a grenade filled with
an unidentifiable form of sleeping gas
with no one to deter them a group of
strange civilians in red robes come
pouring into
scp-2662's room oh great and powerful
Lord of Darkness we come to free you
from this infernal prison one man shouts
brandishing a candelabra filled with lit
black candles oh no thanks I'm good here
but we brought you an offering another
man steps forward tossing a bag of dried
bats onto 2662's bed hey oh man I sleep
there crows Cthulhu groans we have 13
more offerings and then the sacrificial
ritual can commence you just need to
come with us so it can begin the day of
great Freedom when you will Unleash Your
Thousand-Year reign of Madness upon the
land I'm not really into madness I'm
more into OverWatch
scp-2662 backs away from the supplicants
even as they come at him with more and
more grotesque offerings cow tongues
unidentifiable mushrooms one woman tries
to hand him a crying baby he refuses
each one but they are persistent as he
swatting away jars of pickled frogs a
woman begins drawing a circle around the
room and what he hopes is red paint but
fears is something else entirely
um thank you for all these gifts you
have proven yourself as loyal follow
hours I'm going to stay here though to
uh spread the madness from here you you
can all go home he tries to shoot them
out but they continue to press closer
thankfully his rescue finally shows up
task force Town nine swoops in at this
point and begins knocking out and
administering amnestics to all of the
cultists they may not be able to cure
them of their mad devotion but they can
at least make sure the cult forgets the
location of the containment unit at
least for a little while they're able to
dispense with these particular Intruders
humanely but they may need to use lethal
Force for the next ones that's always a
possibility after the cultists have been
removed from the site some maintenance
staff are called in to repair the damage
to the wall where the explosives knocked
it in while they work 2662 goes over his
newspaper one more time making sure he
didn't miss anything attention to detail
is an important skill to have especially
if one intends to get the most out of
their everyday life he finds a few
editorials he he neglected to read
before and enjoys finishing up the
newspaper in its entirety 4pm after the
task force returns to their stations and
the maintenance crew has finished fixing
the wall
scp-2662 turns to one of his newest
Hobbies he attempted to hide this
Pursuit from the foundation at first but
they agreed to let him try it out as
long as he followed some safety
precautions so now at around 4 pm every
day
scp-2662 streams on his very own twitch
Channel he never uses identifying
information and keeps his camera turned
off the entire time plus the internet
sees his tentacle to face but he does
talk to the few viewers in his chat via
a microphone what's up it's squidboy
2662 back to play some games for you
guys again hope you're all having a
killer day and thanks for tuning in
today I'm going to be checking out Apex
Legends for the very first time a lot of
you recommended this game to me so I'm
stoked to check it out as a small fan
Community watches
scp-2662 tries out the popular
MMORPG and plays his way through it for
several hours one person in the chat
asks if he has ever heard of the quote
great tentacled Beast of Legend but he
makes sure to block them before they
give the rest of the chat any ideas he
doesn't want people to watch his streams
because he's some famous elder god or
something he wants to be liked for who
he is 7pm every gamer needs to break for
some fuel and
scp-2662 is no exception at around 7 he
wraps up his stream thanks all of his
viewers and subscribers and gets ready
to have some dinner he throws on another
podcast this time an actual play podcast
following a tabletop gaming campaign and
digs into his last meal of the day like
all his other meals it varies from day
to day but most of the time he goes with
his favorite pizza a big cheese pizza
delivered from a local pizza shop by a
delivery boy who has received more than
his fair share of amnestics and can
never remember why exactly this random
unmarked building seems so familiar
punching on his pizza and listening to
Tales of magic and Mayhem acted out by a
group of friends at a game table
scp-2662 can't help but feel just a
little Melancholy he's happy with what
he has of course but he dreams of a
normal life the kind of life where he
and his friends could play games
together or record a podcast where he
could share this pizza with someone else
but he might not ever have that and it's
something that he has to accept he can
still choose to appreciate what he has
rather than mourn what he doesn't after
he's finished eating and the episode is
finished it's back to the normal grind
at the computer he turns on the Sims for
a little while constructing the kind of
normal life he'd like to fantasize about
sometimes but then one of his Sims burns
down the house while trying to make eggs
and he gives up on that particular
Endeavor to play some Minecraft 11 pm
Some Nights the excitement keeps
scp-2662 awake and playing his games
until the Wii hours of the morning
tonight however he finds himself
exhausted from an unexpectedly
action-packed day courtesy of those
cultists he Powers down the game turns
on his final podcast of the day a guided
meditation to wind him down for sleep
and climbs into bed tomorrow he'll get
up and do it all again doing his best to
carve out a little bit of Peace in a
strange chaotic World maybe tomorrow
he'll just be left alone allowing to be
himself instead of what everyone expects
him to be you'll just have to stick it
out and see that's the beauty of life
after all tomorrow is always a new day
want to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now go check out a day in
the life of scp-049 and what does
scp-999 do all day hour by hour for more
anomalous daily routines